a lot easier like I have like a horror
element to him yeah the low light above
it may kill me
where you guys watch so at the far cry 5
baby
gather round he just keeps bomb I die
once now it's real personal there are no
no doors he's all through the checkpoint
it out like do they really always have
to roll out of every vehicle so funny so
crazy something this happens every time
you're playing Far Cry 5 it's funny
because although that was hilarious
that's maybe the least of not the least
of what we seen but we've seen plenty of
[ __ ] happen I mean we were watching each
other play on the first day we had the
game and it's almost like every five
seconds something crazy happens in this
open world
yesterday when I was playing co-op with
Jake there's like a truck that was
driving by and there's just a dead deer
that was just being dragged along
obviously not intentional but stuff like
that seems like really dumb and fun like
I feel like this game you know they
always talk about like it's an anecdote
Factory but it feels like they've taken
all the systems and they've just like
cranked it up to 11 where it's like it's
constantly having stuff interacting like
I'm trying to save a hostage and a boar
attacks me and then that boar kills the
hostage and then a cougar attacks me
while I'm trying to kill the boar just
like stuff like that
[Music]
totally and it's ridden think that like
excluding primal but the last one was
four and that stuff did definitely
happen but as you said it was like few
and far between so when it did kind of
happen a deer being dragged by
seamlessly nothing across the street
like would be kind of emergent braking
but now it's just hilarious and you kind
of owned the factor and you also own I
feel like as well as the NPC dumb
dialogue turning up or like the things
that they say in any given situation
doesn't always match up like what's the
one that you had that my buddy Luke
Smith who I love but also he's dumb as
[ __ ] he was he was swimming out of the
henbane River and a bear started
attacking me and clawing me and then I
looked back after having run up the hill
and it starts flying him and as he's
getting his face trended by this massive
grizzly he just shouts something's
coming I know it what tipped you off
Luke you dumb idiot say what you want
about Ubisoft over two years having
yearly Assassin's Creed releases having
a bunch of fire cries now but they make
really good open worlds and I think the
direction they're going now is to get
rid of those mini maps littered with
icons and like with Assassin's Creed
origins watchdogs - to some extent and
especially Far Cry 5 they're going more
for that discovering things I lost
Skyrim breath of the wild they said in
sanskrit origins the compass across the
top of screen they lifted it like right
from skyrim they thought seeing little
icons on that every once in a while was
more encouraged exploration more than
you would just on a mini map where you
see an exclamation point or there's like
bird that you can pick would play like
when i played all therefore card games
is it felt very checklist eve like i'm
gonna pull up the map and like okay i'm
gonna like slowly comb through the
island and like do everything this one
is just a natural progression of on
walking and i see a person and i go and
save them and then they tell you like oh
hey there's this outpost is over there
and then it pops up on your map and it's
always within walking distance so you're
just like okay cool
I'll just go that way so I'm kind of
just like play the game that way and it
feels like you're naturally like
discovering anything again that's the
reward you have for okay well let me
start talking these people
that even again goes on the side of the
road like you you helped someone out yet
you know you liberate someone who's
about to be executed there's a huge begi
stash deep inside the old bright ward
and health mind we're talking guns ammo
stuff we need it's gratifying to like
have them lead you to a prepper stash I
had saved the prepper stashes I feel
like could have been that cut and paste
like Ubisoft system treasure map search
just yeah like one of four right a
bunker a cave whatever it is here it's
you you can see some similarity
sometimes they're very short and you
know there's some story elements still
but they all feel handcrafted and they
all are so rewarding because yes there
is
you know maybe perk magazines or even a
vehicle or cash that's like the icing on
the cake but the best part is like the
design of each one of these sometimes
they're like 15 minutes long like I'll
show you guys I don't know if I should
spoil it but basically you know you go
to the Raptor peak and you start there's
something about a hiking party that gets
lost top and along the way you start
like having just these really great
moments like the one I always think
about is rappelling on a rope and you're
swinging and you hear the rattlesnakes
yeah you just did one of these things
for someone like a designer
intentionally on this little ledge put a
rattlesnake there like that's what I'm
ever thinking is like you [ __ ] like
I'm going to have to do this like gulp
here we go you sure enough the second I
hit the ground a rattlesnake comes and
bites me and that was just like one of
many things along the way of just the
side mission like it just feels so
rewarding again to like go through these
and have it be unexpected as far as like
length and what I'm gonna run into and
all these elements and I like I started
from outposts which are kind of
repetitious there's there is no
repetition I feel like in this game I
also love the prepper stashes for I
think that's where some of the best like
storytelling actually comes into play
like I think the main stories writing is
just kind of okay
forgettable for me at least but like the
they're really flexing like their
environmental storytelling yeah like
muscles with the prepper stashes where
you like find a house and there's like a
bunch of dead people and you find these
notes that kind of explains like what
happened they were trying to get out and
you know they were trying to hide in the
bunker or there's this really great
early one where there's this like tower
we're like a locked door and there's a
note where it's like oh you got to shoot
the lock from the other side across the
river but I'm a crack shot I can
definitely do it
and then you simply here like this
sniper fire and there's this dude who's
just constantly shooting at the door the
other side and you can you go and you
you kill him and then you get this time
here you take a sniper and you look and
there's just like five hundred bullet
holes around the low around the door of
him like he's just been there for hours
trying to snipe it and then I just like
to snipe it in one shot and like go and
take it and like like stuff like that
just like I think that is like the
interesting like mini stories they're
telling like through the world that I
find actually really compelling so the
brilliant part of that side quest is you
could have come into it at any point
it's still what I made sense you could
heard the shots first and then seen him
shooting at any ya know Kim so I saw the
bullet holes on the wall first know like
where those from and then all of a
sudden I heard the shot and then I read
the note and I was like oh that makes
sense
you could have come in at the note and
then heard him shoot you could have
killed him and then looked across and
seen the glowing lock through the window
like I saw him shooting and I was like
shut up and just shot him down climbed
up picked up his gun and then I saw the
glowing lock and I shot it went back
around and was like alright what did
that do did I do anything and then I
read it I read the note and it's like oh
okay just go right in then again go
right in and I'm there that's pretty
cool
as far as people and the GameSpot office
which I think I maybe one other person
really liked Assassin's Creed origins
for its world mainly as some of its
story jkhanner you played it a little
bit like at the review event everything
and then a lot afterward
did you like where would this Far Cry 5
ranked in Ubisoft open worlds you know I
think Assassin's Creed origins kind of
started that change and I in I didn't
love Assassin's Creed origins but it did
some really neat things and it shook up
that formula which I liked and I think
this kind of lifts the cool stuff from
there which they lived from Skyrim and
then it also like you were saying cranks
up the Far Cry nice to 11 and I like to
how the story in this kind of takes a
backseat like even though they were
trying to build up like oh you're gonna
hate that you love Joseph or whatever
his name is Joseph see and like apart
from the intro it's kind of like alright
like that was a chilling intro but then
it's just kind of like you start making
your own stories right away it's almost
like they understand that that no one's
gonna talk about farcry story with each
other like sure they might talk about
the Ville and like loss or just a seed
or whatever but the real stories come
from you know like a bear running out of
the woods and attacking a boar that
you're trying to find and then like like
all the ridiculous stuff that's what's
fun about Parker and I think this does
it very well I think even the side
missions yes like the previous parker
games like okay you got your same three
or four activities that they just kind
of littered throughout the map this one
it's all the side missions are like
unique they have characters you need
dialogues or doing any activities you're
helping cows have sex
last thing I think we're talking about
how you come across quest I love I think
your companions in this game are
essential and obviously that goes back
to far cry too
there were like iterations of this in
Far Cry 4 and the primal had the animals
which also is heavily in this with
peaches the Cougar boomer the dog
cheeseburger the bear yeah
I think companions are essential because
like Rob yours plane earlier and you
went down into a bunker of which there
are money because it's like survivalists
doomsday prepper bunkers that you run
across in this role Montana but then you
hear gunshots up above and I think the
companions its despite being dumb
despite their dialogue replaying itself
like on a constant basis I think they
work really well in this crazy game
because you'll hear gunshots up on the
surface and like firefights will start
when you're not even a part of them but
you also go up and you know exactly you
know exactly like oh I'm gonna defend
cheeseburger and I see him mauling him
so that must be an enemy you even before
you see the market like the companions
are great and they will get into their
own conflicts apart from you if you're
just doing your own thing trying to
explore and I think that just makes the
world not it doesn't feel realistic in
any way so the opposite realistically
but this world itself is organic like it
makes this world makes sense within
itself it's not realistic compared to
the real world but it's like it makes
sense as far as like these systems
overlapping all have a strict kind of
rule set they follow and it's funny to
see the rules get bent and that's what
makes this one so fun like kind of
harkening back to it's funny when
Assassin's Creed origins was very much
about discoverability this one's like
that with the added like anecdote
factory like you mentioned like they've
been almost all the view be soft
internal studios are going toward now
like watchdogs to I know they kind of
kick-started it and now they're going
that way with Far Cry 5 and I don't know
I'm curious see where they go after
people that were tipped
but in general I think this is I don't
know if I want to say to my favorite
Ubisoft open-world game and I'm only
comparing them because some of their
internal Studios use the same engines
the same philosophies but I think it's
up there it's like this and Assassin's
Creed origins or Black Flag for me
personally probably my one of my
favorite open roles they've done in a
while and I think a lot of that has to
do with the way they're presenting it
the way you're discovering stuff and we
don't really talk about it much but the
setting like I absolutely like love like
the setting of Montana and lions fields
in the Rocky you know like mountains and
the forest having like been to places
like the on vacation like there's a
nostalgia I feel when I'm playing this
game and like it's just really beautiful
yeah it's a gorgeous game it doesn't run
me at the time I got by a bear and ran
over by an ATV it's coming right for us
god I hate Luke he's such an idiot
but I bring him everywhere
[Music]